hey everyone Dave here and what I want
to show you today is 20 minutes of Dawn
of War 3 1v1 multiplayer gameplay I'm
playing as the space marines feel free
to place your bets on whether I win or
lose this match in the comments and if
you enjoyed make sure you like the video
the space rings are pretty Hardy
warriors so don't be afraid to get stuck
in with them I'm facing the Elder and my
objective is to take down their
generator you do this by disabling
shields and destroying turrets to make
their base vulnerable first one to kill
the enemies generator wins the match if
you have any dawn of all questions feel
free to leave them in the comments below
or tweet them at me at a regular Dave
and I'll do my best to answer them until
then I'll shut up and let you enjoy the
gameplay
[Music]
tactical tactical tactic doing it now
let's serve it already country mine go
ahead come on hi come on
price smells the air
our enemies
prepare to all my ones
our brothers are met by our Yost anomie
for Joshua to the southwest we are ready
for war yes command Huntsman
loud and clear
carrying out orders
you
assaults hwadam look to our vulnerable
listening post ring night Bibles actor
under we have engaged to will see enemy
for us to slay Southwood
there's a storm this one would comply
I'll kill him I saluted em no Eddie the
alien our brothers are met by a los
enemy force Northwoods you can't defend
this place
Buchholz of island poisons PJs
we
this day hold fluorine I say
[Music]
brother Raymond I agree recount of his
walk
especially going now tactical squad
Oh
come on
the red calendars
Oh
Keltie
I have their scent
u.s. xenos for us to say on the moon
Angelo's with starcast - holy Sh not gay
point as you order receive Amite let us
get to we persist to this has it all
with me priming chance
our attorneys for deploy my you drop hot
days online streak and see Cory gun go
ahead
guilty my elder phone kostik women
challenge tactical marine squatting
water
we all
I still asked running checks assault
blurriness
[Music]
careful
ready very good
serve it all is equipped for
construction
oh you machine pelt us
we're ready for
we have engaged a week and - northward
what is your order
moving reading readying remember sooner
brain cells Walter
don't marines readying for drop fills
the air
our brothers are met by a weak enemy
force northwards our new battle brothers
are ready to deploy at your word
we are the Inquisition's fire
dreadnaught on roots canceling
deployment
tactical squad on routes
he will fight yes sir Herbert smile
assault Marines report ready to drop
your ass dog
whirlwind artillery battery deployed
transformer and joined the battle
we already moving the Inquisition zones
that is us
Marine squad deployed
under way just Park deployed
and this will stand
people to devastators await your orders
ready upon the feet
- one reported moving
well
upgrading strouhal to tier 3 preparing
tactical Marines for deployment
engineer on site we have engaged the
weak enemy force this one obeys
as tail
preparing doctor home use the toilet
[Music]
deployed this threat
is ready to come on
infantry damage upgrade secure I still
serve you have me heading out
this one tactical swarm we are ready to
revile carry out what we've upgraded
infantry health
unleash the ultimate ability
really
Green Freddy
vehicle durability isn't
Destructo with pleasure
I will not shutting out let's go nuts
your best cannons moving out we have
engaged a week silly Freddie to the
southwest chapter come on punch we
escalated to the final phases and team
the Emperor lights our way vehicle
weaponry is improved
predator Annihilator readying for drop
even fights with me shall be my brother
Angelo's
launching there now
in tactical squad on routes assault
squad on route
preparing dreadnought for deployment
you have my favor tactical resource that
they are on tactical Marines ready
flavor
tactical Marines got deployed
we have engaged the weak enemy force
Northwoods tactical Marines report that
they are on site
tacticals we're ready upgrading to
flamin tactical squad along
Meital day
join underway
you
you